[Music]
tv tv on the wall who's the dumbest of
them all
yes the world deserves to know which cnn
hack is curly and which one is mo
last night i proclaimed chris cuomo as
the second dumbest man on cnn that's
like being the second drunkest
slow-pitched softball player
but of that network the competition is
fierce for my money don lemon remains
the champion but not everyone agreed
including tucker carlson
chris cuomo really gets the credit he
deserves for being the single dumbest
person ever to perform on cable news he
makes don lamont look like a particle
physicist
so by comparison he makes don lamont
look like a particle physicist
or as chris cuomo might call it make
things go boom doctor guy
so is it time to decide who has fewer
brains inside short of an autopsy
there's only one way to find out
the great tucker carlson greg gutfeld
debate
tonight's debate which host replaced his
brain with a steel plate
joining me now host of tucker carlson
tonight and tucker carlson today it's
tucker carlson
thank you greg
it's a friendly chat with tucker about
two stupid
but before we get started let's take a
look at some clips tucker and remind
people who we're dealing with first
let's start with tucker's choice mr
cuomo
only in america kids let's get after it
the official
re-entry from the basement
cleared by cdc a little sweaty just
worked out happens please show me where
it says that protests are supposed to be
polite and peaceful in scale
this was the actual swab that was being
used
to fit up that double barrel shotgun
that you have mounted on the front of
your pretty face
you know no doubt that was pretty dumb
but can don b beat that
democratic cities are in chaos right now
oh my gosh it's so bad and again
defunding police it's like
the president is a racist and he is a
demagogue believing the lies on the
internet instead of science it's time to
start shaming them what else or leave
them behind nothing wrong with botox
people don't know what they eat look
at it my eyebrow went up i don't have it
now as you can see i got all these
wrinkles everybody asked me when i'm
going to get you getting botox
both stupid so i contend that while
cuomo makes dumber decisions than lemon
lemon is just naturally slower cuomo is
more of a performer where lemon just
speaks his mind which explains his
stupidity so tucker persuade me that i
am incorrect let me just say we
we disagree but we don't need to be
disagreeable we're friends i don't want
this in any way to affect our
long-standing friendship i agreed with
you for many years i thought that chris
cuomo was putting on an act
you know the weight lifting the
calling the bro talk
the huge swap i thought he was like
bowser on shanana who actually went to
colombia do you know what i mean it was
a part what a reference and then i
watched him because i used to work at
cnn i know people there i pay attention
that guy is every bit as stupid as he
seems he went to yale law school his dad
was a governor of new york at the time
and he doesn't know what's in the first
amendment
he has zero sense of humor which is
always a tell but here
is the absolute
settling factor
he speaks only in cliches
if you listen carefully to chris cuomo
you will find not a single phrase
that you can't instantly get on
instagram
all of it
so dumb people speaking cliches don
lemon by contrast not a genius
but he gets the joke
like he sort of knows i'm a guy with no
skills i was a local news anchor in
atlanta and look where i am now he finds
the whole thing hilarious right
all right so okay that was fairly
persuasive i'm gonna have the audience
vote after we have we get to the point
of this but for i will say that don
lemon uh it was uh his stupidity was
unmatched when he claimed that violence
in the cities didn't exist because he
just went out and had a nice meal
so it's like somebody like he is in a
full he and i honestly you could he
he he
felt that because he was recognized he
was on the street oh and they recognized
me it was great i had a nice meal
therefore there were no assaults and
homicides in new york city correct
that's not stupidity that's narcissism
he lives in a don le mans bubble and
everything is great in don lemon world
at all times and that's kind of what i
like about him
so you actually so you enjoy don lemon
because he's he's not very bright and he
knows it
he's mr rourke from fantasy island
welcome to don le mans world
i mean there's
so corinthian leather about him so
unbelievably cheesy in a 1979 way that i
just i don't know he he pushes my
buttons
boy you really are diplomatic who would
you want so i was going to ask you who
would you you fish a lot who would you
like to go fishing with would it be
obviously would have to be with dawn
don lemon in a very famous interview on
the record at lunch referred in fact
ordered for dessert
lemon sorbet
and when corrected he said no no no i'm
afraid it's brown sorbet he did not
acknowledge
that he had no idea how to pronounce the
frozen dessert and he wasn't embarrassed
so my dream is to have a long dinner
with don lamont
do you know what uh i think what unites
both of those uh candidates for dumbest
person at cnn is the lack of
embarrassment like they they go out
there they deliver the same tripe every
day but they wake up and they're as
happy as clams no no i disagree i
disagree chris cuomo is totally
tormented you watch chris cuomo and
there's a deep self-loathing like he
knows how dummy is and he's mad about it
that's that's what the
anabolic steroids are about
obviously um i don't know don lamont is
totally happy in his
mindless haze i want to ask the panel
here uh who is who's being most most
persuasive here dave well i think
tucker's winning here but i think the
next time you guys do this you need to
widen the net to msnbc because get joy
read in there
and then
and then it's almost impossible but no
we don't we could do that yeah but we
could just pit joy reid against uh he
weaponizes it nicole wallace
i think next week we could do joy reid
versus uh nicole wallace or we could do
brian stelter versus brianna keller is
that her name tucker
oh the former morning zoo girl from the
am radio show and yeah
yeah she's not even on the list she
doesn't qualify
by the way the woman not joy reid the
other one on msnbc is so loathsome i am
proud to say i have never uttered her
name
since i met her in 1999 when she was jeb
bush's flack she was nasty and stupid
then she's worse now ugh worst person
you know this might be the greatest
segment i see a guy looking at me with
it concentrating well i'm just amazed by
the expertise that you both have about
these cnn programs are you the only
people in america who watch these
shows man
actually you make the point the people
who watch those shows are dumber than
lauren clomo combined they watch it
because it's so damn funny it's the
funniest show it's funnier than the late
night comics tucker we gotta roll thank
you so much for participating in our
inaugural debates and giving time and
we're still friends thank you dave thank
you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else